it is always a good day when there's a
new nintendo direct
they're my favorite i never know what to
expect today we're actually getting the
second trailer for pokemon scarlet and
pokemon violet not technically a
nintendo direct but in that category
um pokemon trailers also make me very
happy i'm thinking that i'm gonna go
with pokemon violet at this point but
maybe
the second trailer that just dropped
today on nintendo's youtube channel will
help to inform me further let me confirm
that yes no sorry the official pokemon
youtube channel we're watching this on
at the time recording it has 2.3
million views so
let's do it
[Music]
very good
[Music]
y'all are hot
not the cat
oh
my god
why is everybody so sexy
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
wait wait that's a thing that you can do
in this game
did this foreplay a co-op
how did i not know that already maybe i
did and i forgot
that's cool as hell
[Music]
stupid hair
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
is that it
okay not quite it's like wow that went
are fast gonna get a legendary
[Music]
very again just everything's very sexy
this this is a floating
big pulse
this is look at that oh my god
look okay
he's also ridiculous they're both very
ridiculous looking
i hate both the legendaries that's a
shame
that's a shame
okay
um
go back to the just the actual standing
shots of them here
sometimes people don't like new things i
think they look terrible and i think
what it is is the there are too many
conflicting colors
i still think i prefer violet
even though it looks like
the silhouette is a dick and balls um
it's okay i'll get used to it i always
do i always do uh this is a cute trailer
really fast action-packed
just
le chunk i'm loving this guy's hair oh
i'm too big hang on
this yeah a little elvis hair this man's
got incredible work incredible work
um
there were some other things that i
thought were cool like obviously the
full black cup if they had announced
that i completely missed it and i would
like to know more about that because
that sounds awesome i don't know
the details of that that sounds super
cool let me look it up okay looks like
this was just announced today
uh pokemons this is by ign pokemon
scarlet and violet will include four
player call-up in addition to its
regular trading and battling multiplayer
announced on the game's website
following the unveiling of its release
date in a new trailer i completely even
skipped the release date
scala and violet promise a deeper
experience with multiplayer
opening the door gamepl an adventure
more
previous and fun than ever
more
previous
am i reading that right did somebody
make a mistake
the world of pokemon
the
pokemon in scarlet and pokemon violet
had added an extra and there games the
newest chapters in the pokemon series
are coming to nintendo switch later this
year with these new titles the pokemon
series takes a new evolutionary step
allowing you to explore freely in a
ritually expressed open world wow that's
cool i i actually suspected that based
on the way that um
the encounters were taking place
it did look open world
and the weather effects of us more
interesting is it regional
is it
time based like animal crossing
[Music]
the world of pokemon has evolved pokemon
skull and pokemon violet offer an open
world experience that only the pokemon
series can deliver one welcoming even to
newcomers to the series you can
experience a new style of adventure with
a world that you're freaked to explore
at a leisure and not in an order
dictated by the story that is very cool
that's super cool you will of course
journey to hone your skills as a pokemon
trainer but many more discoveries and
stories await you meet a variety people
in pokemon and adventure in the world of
pokemon the way you want to
some nice screens for you there
a deeper experience with multiplayer
gameplay
pokemon skull and pokemon violet allow
multiplayer gameplay with up to four
players along with series staples such
as trading and battling pokemon you'll
be able to explore the various locations
of the region in these games with other
players you can discover new pokemon and
explore unfamiliar areas this is
basically what i said um more precious
that's why ign said
previous the word is actually precious
that makes a lot more sense i'm glad i
checked
opening the door to an adventure more
precious and fun
than ever
that's really cool
i did not see that coming
um and i'm absolutely stoked about it
that is awesome
have any more information
no we don't have any details i guess uh
ign is probably just going off of
exactly what's on the
blog post there as well
we don't know if there are specific
multiplayer areas for example the move
would seem to go hand in hand with the
games more open structure
yeah i'd hope it's the whole open world
but i doubt it'll be that way just based
on
prior knowledge
i doubt that they will be open while
games players go to visit areas in any
order without the story getting progress
the trailer above seems to back this up
as a feature multiplayer seemingly
showing four players in a single game
exploring very different areas
simultaneously
very very cool yeah it's not clear how
transferring pokemon between regions
will work
i wonder how like pvp works will that be
approached differently a lot of
questions um
yeah it's not clear how those
traditional multiplayer elements will be
affected by cop either it seems very
possible that pokemon scarlet and violet
may allow users to join each other's
games not just to explore but also
battle and trade it should be very neat
i wonder if we'll have codes like i have
so many questions about how this is
going to work but i think it's awesome
we do seem to see remote trading taking
place in the trailer too i didn't notice
that
very cool i think these are just
probably screenshots there oh yeah
that's really neat um it's the first
time in a while that there's been like a
new feature in a pokemon game that i've
actually been really excited about they
draw me in every time with the pokemon
it's like with the way they look the
starters the regions uh sometimes too
but
in this case it's a feature and that's
actually really exciting it's been a
long time
since i've been excited about a feature
since i feel like they've innovated a
whole lot um
that's very very cool
it looks fine
slash bad
fans get mad at me whenever i say that
though some of them i guess are
aggressively on my side
that like this is a repeated texture um
they don't they don't look great but
i'll take it for the open world
hmm
i wonder how much that's going to change
like the structure of leveling and and
are jim's going to scale with you or is
it going to be like an eldering type
situation where you explore the open
world and you go somewhere and you go
this is clearly too hard i need to go
back to caled or whatever
which nobody ever said
hmm
very cool very cool also i completely
missed the the release date let me hang
on let me just open this up and
readjust my screen a little
that seems fine
release date probably at the end here i
didn't even look at it if i'm 18. that
makes sense that makes sense
uh should we read some comments
[Laughter]
i hopefully chunk evolves into lithic
yeah dude i really want a pokemon game
it feels like coliseum
uh the legendaries are gonna become
bikes or rideable in some way oh that's
a good take
because they do have like sort of bikes
on their chests
it explains the tyre like things coming
out of their chest not only that but
they both have a handle like thing
coming out of their heads and also the
pokemon centers look like gas stations
that is a really interesting thought
because they do
i don't know about the handles yeah you
can make them both have both applied
handles and if they're ridable in the
open world
that's also very cool
so i already felt like this one was
going to be big it's the first one my
daughter and i are both excited for
she'd pick violet and i picked scarlet
with the first trailer and then i saw
this and i loved every second and
something struck me i've been playing
pokemon since red and blue and now i'm
finally going to pass it on to my child
in earnest okay this doesn't seem to be
about the game this is a very sweet
comment
i didn't even see it coming but i have
become the professor giving her a
starter to send her on a grand adventure
and with the theme being past in future
it's all too perfect thank you for
bringing the series that meant so much
for growing up
and now i hope i will mean
now i hope will mean the same to my
family that is a very very sweet thought
it's like one very compelling reason to
have children is to introduce some video
games
legendaries look sick i wonder if i'm
alone i really don't like the way they
look i think they look really silly
great the region looks pretty good
waiting to see what some of the cities
and towns look like yes on that my
friend already said he's picking the
grass type starter because it's cute the
grass type starter is very cute it's
just gonna end up standing though like
it's gonna go from four legged and cute
to
to standing like we know that already
wait and see what the final evolutions
look like i think i would prefer to do
that too
uh but i'm going violet because purple
is my favorite color
this is the first pokemon game in a long
time that i'm actually really excited
about i can't wait to see why i think i
agree like i'm always interested
the features hmm all right i'm gonna
stop repeating myself
looks cool i think the legendaries look
ridiculous that's okay
i don't like them at all the co-op
though
that's awesome